[Music]
in August of 2015 TCS announced right
here on campus that they would make the
largest corporate gift in CMU history
and the largest gift to CMU from outside
the United States in our history TCS s
capacity as a leader in global IT
services will be a tremendous asset as
the key ingredients of the fourth
Industrial Revolution such as artificial
intelligence and robotics machine
learning big data and deep data
analytics the Internet of Things and
cybersecurity become increasingly
relevant in everyday life today we are
not looking at heavy metal and millions
of tons of steel we're looking at a
collaboration of mental skills and the
development of two countries together
that might bring about global
understanding between
I want to thank suber surest for his
great leadership in this region the TCS
CM your relationship and partnership is
one that I am sure will be very again
beneficial to both entities it is a
great privilege for TCS to establish
this Theseus hall and partner with CMU
to promote the pioneering work in all
these technologies so that we are able
to create a better future better world
for all of us